oh man
I've never even felt the wind right
there
Jason Momoa has a new look so
shaving off the hair the actor chopping
off his signature locks and debuting a
dramatic new buzz cut all for a Cause
do it for uh
single-use Plastics
I'm tired of these plastic bottles Jason
shows off his hair transformation on
Instagram it's all to bring attention to
Jason's campaign to get people to use
recyclable and aluminum products instead
of plastic we gotta stop
plastic forks all that just goes into
our land goes into our ocean I'm here in
Hawaii right now
I'm just saying
things in our ocean it's just so sad so
please
anything you can do
to eliminate single-use Plastics in your
lives
help me the actor has yet to share a
snap of his completed look but he teases
the process of the final haircut in his
post aloha
we're gonna keep going oh man
City Girl
all right I love you guys he ends the
clip sharing a glimpse of his own
reusable water bottle hoping his message
is loud and clear
[Music]
yeah this isn't the first time Jason's
raised awareness for a cause last month
he pulled this stunt in the air
promoting his own water company handing
out aluminum bottles to airline
passengers mid-flight
he launched the business back in 2019
which came with another style switch up
Jason shaving his equally as iconic
beard
I just want to do this to bring
awareness
Plastics are killing our planet Jason's
long been known for his Lush locks
which had grown past his shoulders when
ET spoke with him just a few weeks back
for season three of his Apple TV Plus
show C
I mean obviously I'm a father and a
family man and um
there was just a lot I didn't have the
opportunity to play it Dad in the series
before I love having a full Arc I
decided to just killed off in the first
season or or it's just doesn't end
properly it's nice that it's three
seasons and it's catered to
you know the the Final Chapter you get
to go through everything and you get to
see what happens and it was intended
that way
[Music]